Let's also look at examples of what happens when we change the lens that has
a different focal length.
Let's look at the example we have looked at before, a tree,
a lens, an images of a lens here.
Of course, let's assume that this lens has a focal length of three inches.
So this time around, I'm only going to change the lens and
give it another lens with a different focal length.
So now, we have another lens, this lens has a focal length of say six inches.
Remember, we want the image to be formed, at the focal plane of this lens,
so now, the best image that will be formed at this focal length,
because of the fact that it's farther away would be larger than this one.
So just, by changing the lens focal length,
we notice that the image formed is much bigger.
So this allows us to now basically be able to
control how we form images on our sensor, by changing the focal length,
we can actually play around and generate different types of images, and
most times, the focal length f could be longer, or shorter.
And we will see examples of the impact of this on what kinds of
images are formed in a bit.
Now remember, focal lengths are specific to lenses themselves when they're
manufactured, most of times, of course, when you see complex lenses, you'll also
get a variety of lenses composited together and the dynamics of these lenses,
are the ones that give you the effective focal length of that lens.
In this case, of course we're just simplifying all of our lenses to
be just one simple lens here.